I love every show when you come out and  dance I actually look forward now we're  just seeing that move she's gonna do the  same moves but what's weird about it is  I'm trying to break down why I like that  I think it's because I expect that you  can't dance you know what I mean like  Ellen DeGeneres can't dance uh-huh or  would not even want to uh-huh but that  someone told me that you hate dancing at  this point but it's almost as if the  audience demands and you want to stop  dancing that you can't what's the truth  there it's somewhere in between I don't  like when I'm out in public and people  start yelling at me to dance that's bad  yeah like like you're like Fred Astaire  really like there's no music and I'm  just in like you know a doctor's office  dance and that's what I hear all the  times when you hear when people say that  are you saying yourself Oh dance monkey  yes exactly yeah I said well I answer  them sometimes I say there's no music